I I I I I I
could never have done what what you did
you know in order to I love competition
you see yeah me too me too but I just
even with yourself competing with
yourself but I just think it takes a a
certain level of courage and confidence
to be able to go on on a show yeah and
break through that way I mean I'm it's
I'm not you know being modest or
anything I could never have done that I
I know what I'm capable of which is
hysterical though because your voice is
like what people are like I wouldn't
have done it I I I wouldn't have it it
takes a I think a certain amount of
courage to put yourself out there and be
judged in amongst other people right and
be critiqued on a show on a world stage
I I don't know if anyone realizes how
hard that is you know to to actually put
yourself out there and people tell you
how good you were or how bad you were
and you haven't take it you know on a
show like you did I I wouldn't have had
the courage to do that and and I so I
have so much admiration well thank you I
think the really good boot camp though
because it was really hard and it was
more hard not for me but to watch other
I'm always that person like it's hard
for me to watch other people go through
something and like other artists were
not handling it well like what people
would say online and and it was the
first time the show was on or whatever
so it was that that was harder watching
people you know break their Spirit a bit
um yeah I think and that that sucks but
I will say it was a great boot camp
because
after that I felt like I mean this
industry is hard you say you couldn't
handle it but you did because this
industry is not easy even if you're
selling eight million albums or doing
whatever there's always people just
trying to knock you down or say
something just super I can't say that on
TV but you went but you went from
nothing to all of a sudden that's the
trick though that's why I think that is
the key when you have no home my place
had burned down I was living in my car
for a bit I had no like I had nothing I
had nothing and I think when you have
nothing you have nothing to lose so you
just show up and you go sure you can
laugh but if I'm getting paid I'm
laughing all the way to the bank
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]